and caring Gordon
also have to tell people what you want
them to do don't just say check out my
web series though dude I said people
will do what you tell them to do if you
say check out my web series and post a
comment they will check out our nando
post a comment okay and comments are
more important than views because you
can actually go back and use that to
your advantage sick and sponsorships and
saying okay this is what people are
saying about the show you know they like
it this is what they saying would you at
least help on me and I should so many
ways to promote yourself but you're
sitting up there and you have to get
away from the computer people are just
so used to sitting on the computer and
type in a way you have to get away from
the computer and build personal
relationships with people it is king
that is key not yeah I i love i love you
mentioning connecting with people and i
also love you mentioned be specific you
know don't just tell people you play the
exact because you know I've come across
as well you want if you're looking for
action then share what that action is
with the audience so they know what to
do